that's a good one
this is a really really fun way to walk
down memory lane and to relive all of
these
memories that we have or things that
we've blocked out
for some reason the kardashians reenact
some of the most
iconic keeping up scenes leading up to
the series finale
oh my gosh such a gift it all went down
during part one of the series finale
when the famous family took one last
getaway for the show
to lake tahoe and decided to play a fun
little game
i thought we would do a scavenger hunt
oh
yeah i'll let kris jenner explain the
rules
this amazing scavenger hunt that
represents the years on the show each
team is going to have
a polaroid camera that you see in front
of you both
teams have a list of significant
things that have happened on the show
and we're going to take a picture
when we find items that represent those
moments
we're gonna tally up all the photos
whoever has the most photos that are
correct
win the game it's a good thing i'm not
doing this while i'm drinking
the teams chloe kendall chris and her
boyfriend corey gamble
versus kim courtney and scott disick
sounds simple enough right
honestly some of these answers are
harder than i thought
like i don't know some of them and i
lived it
yeah things got off to a rocky start
when kim got the very first hint
wrong okay kim buys this anniversary
gift in a
in the very first episode of season one
what anniversary who was i with season
one
the is it a photo shoot
yes it's an american a calendar
nice yeah i want to see a little bit
more yeah exactly right like that
the correct answer can't find him
writing anniversary gifting very first
episode
oh a stripper oh my god
okay i had to get the right angle yeah
kim bought her mom and caitlyn jenner a
stripper pole for their anniversary
season one episode one it was a lot of
fun
and if all that wasn't sexy enough chris
brought back her memorable nude photo
shoot thanks to this prompt
any proper creative element in a nude
photo shoot a flag remember mom had a
flag over her
naked body show the ass i feel like i'm
in the gynecologist's office
can we just do one with the boobs
exposed it's amazing
oh my god
if we don't win of course it wouldn't be
a proper keeping up throwback without
the
infamous purse moment oh my god
yeah you know the one kardashian
fighting weapon of choice
okay we got nails i'm hitting mom with a
purse
don't be [ __ ] rude are you kidding me
that's a good one and remember that
super scary car accident in montana when
chloe was behind the wheel in season
10.
[Music]
coco reenacted that too
the fun activity also had the fam
reminiscing about that time scott
channeled his inner ryan gosling a la
the notebook in season seven
i can't quit you don't you get it
the moment chris bought a chicken coop
in season two
chloe chloe chloe
and that time chloe posed naked in a
bathtub
full of gumballs
[Music]
no cute
it's adorable that's a trigger for me
the bathtub
what a stroll down memory lane
we had so much fun so who won all right
what's our score
21 we have 23.
good win of course this season marks the
20th and final season of keeping up with
the kardashians
this is insane but have no fear because
the kardashian jenners will be back on
tv
in no time since they inked a major new
deal with hulu
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen
you